you don't happen to own a cat do you
well almost owning a cat doesn't do me
any good yeah I have a bit of a weird
question for you do you have a cat all
right do you have any like really close
friends who have cats hey I think we're
gonna have to wait till Thursday on the
cat licking good morning Hank it's
Tuesday August 14th the day of my
punishment hi can I have a hamburger
happy meal please with an orange drink
is it for a boy or a girl
a girl we have gender-specific happy
meals now I don't think this represents
progress Hank how do you think this is
gonna go I think it's gonna go better
than the gigawatts okay with like one
being a baby pinched me and ten being I
just waxed my chin where do you think
the pain is gonna fall but you think
it's a five all right Hank welcome to
cooking with John Green now I'm going to
blend a happy meal I got the orange
drink something just told me that it was
going to be better we're putting some of
the orange drink I'm going to save a
little bit to help wash down the rest of
what I'm about to do open it up french
fries telecon hardy-cross hamburger it's
quite a lot of food actually we're raiga
blend
now that disappoints delicious like all
the best parts of food to us all the
best parts of wicked I see little bits
of gristle that's nice it just just
doesn't smell like something that you
should be eating the spoon here if you
I already got one spoon in and I feel
like puking I eat spoonful after
spoonful it was
can solve
my life I'm really glad I didn't say I'd
eat at McDonald's extra value meal
because that would have killed me I can
see a little bit of pickle fish no more
happy meal no matter how much this hurts
little man it's not going to be as bad
as the last thing if you told me on
January 1st 2007 that we would be doing
this they would know to believe you 1 2
3 oh boy oh wow that was not a 5 that is
not a 5 I would rather wax my entire
body head to toe than ever you blender
is happy meal ever again last one 1 2 3
oh hey I have done some serious waxing
and I'll see you singing tomorrow